i wanted to add a little personal note
to the top of show
i'm someone who puts a tremendous amount
of pressure on myself and that is
putting it so politely
i'm like and i
live in that pressure cooker state and
the other day for some
unknown to me reason i thought can you
think about the things that you've done
rather than you need to do and i took
some inventory
and so i thought as an exercise as we
make all of our to-do lists
try to maybe make a have done list
as well and i see people nodding their
heads in the wall and i can't tell you
what a sense of community i feel right
now so thank you for this moment it
means a lot to me
and of course as soon as i had it i
thought well what do i do with it let's
share it
all right now ironically i would like to
introduce you to someone
who already has a have done list
at her age that is so incredibly
impressive
it blows my mind okay imagine setting
out to feed the hungry
shelter the homeless and help those who
are less fortunate
at just seven years old
and now at age 14 double the number
sanya perani from minneapolis minnesota
has created the organization sonya's
hope for children
in order to help young people get the
supplies they need
to succeed so without further ado
and everything aside can we please
welcome
sonya
hello and may i ask um will you explain
what sonya's hope for children is
well sonia's hope for children is a
501c3
student-led non-profit founded in
20 2017 january
and we're focused on children helping
children and our mission is that we
strongly believe that every child
deserves basic human rights like food
shelter clothes safety and education
you are just incredible will you please
tell us about the latest project that
you're
working on i believe it's collecting
toys for homeless children
yeah so this project is called our
christmas bag project
and we take volunteers my own son is
helper children
a team and myself we all sew these bags
and then we have donations of school
supplies toys and books
which are then put into the bags during
an event
and then for this year they will be
delivered to homeless shelters around
minnesota
well we'd like to help we're going to
donate ten thousand dollars to sonia's
hope for children
to help you continue the amazing work
that you do
oh my god that's so amazing i really
appreciate it thank you so much
wow that is um thank you for setting an
example
for us all and we're gonna have your
organization up on our website
you're just you're just incredible i'm
so honored that you came on the show
well i am so glad to have this
opportunity to come on the show
meeting with you has been so amazing i
am so appreciative of you
thank you so much right back at you
thank you sonya
thank you we'll see you soon and check
back in with you
[Music]